[Music]
in this video I'm gonna be showing you
how to program your blank chip key for
your Toyota if your car only came with
one key buy these blank chip keys when
buying your new key make sure it's the
right key as you see this one has a dot
Maya the one doesn't generic keys are
blank you're gonna need to cut them and
program them not a program a new key you
want to take an already programmed key
inserted in the ignition and remove it
five times on the fifth time you want to
leave it in now you want to open and
close the driver's door six times now
you want to remove the key out of the
ignition once you remove the key from
the ignition the security lights gonna
stay on indicating you're in programming
mode in programming mode you want to
insert the new key in the ignition
with the new key in the ignition the
security lights gonna blink for about 60
seconds once the light stops flashing
start the car up if you have another key
to program repeat this exact same
procedure for your other key so I hope
this video was helpful in showing you
how to program your new chip key on your
Toyota